we got to start with the most
anticipated film of the year falling for
Christmas with Lindsay Lohan did she
share her plans for getting back into
the business with both feet uh I mean
she's she's very I think she has a
massive planned rollout plan for a lot
of things coming up and I'm super
excited to see what she does with it um
but she's she's very you know with it
and professional and uh
it was it was just a blast and really
easy fun environment yeah I mean it's
good to hear because obviously you know
when she was coming up there were always
like stories about how like hiding in a
closet or whatever it is and but your
experience was was good and like on the
level I wasn't around any closets like
this so I I don't I don't know uh
um yeah no it was it was really fun like
uh you know we got down there and we
were in Park City for like two months
and uh we just bunkered down and had a
great time and uh it was just really
chill and easy and I mean you can't not
have a good time when everything around
is like Christmas feels so it was like
it was like Christmas for like three
months for me that year that's amazing
yeah alrighty you went through the lost
and found
are these used probably but you know
sometimes guests leave things here by
accident so I'm not sure this was left
here by accident
had you guys ever crossed paths when you
guys were coming up uh kind of briefly
here and there just like a small little
uh run-ins but uh not not more than like
a handshake did she bring bait or did
you guys get to spend some time together
yeah they actually got engaged while we
were down there and she brought her
brother down there and uh her brother
and me uh hit it off and he's pretty
much like my little brother now uh you
know so like the whole last day when it
finally snowed down there in between
takes we were having a constant like
four hour snowball fight oh my God but
we have a great time and uh I got to
hang with them a lot and they're just
great people
now
look beautiful what can you tell me
about this it's sort of similar to
overboard right yeah uh this is it's
such a fun uh flick but it's it's uh
it's this heiress of this kind of Hotel
Empire and I own the small you know tiny
Lodge on the mountain and she bumps her
head and loses her memory of who she is
and uh I take her into my small Lodge
and try to jog her memory and
I dare her to not fall in love with me
you know
you dare of course you can't resist
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
do you guys do a little like Mean Girls
style like song and dance number in the
film
um no she definitely sings
um
what's the song she sings in Mean Girls
Jingle Bell Rock like a little carpool
karaoke type thing in the in the movie
um uh but we don't do a duet in this one
though I like that though but you've got
the but you've got a Christmas song for
is it an original or is it one yeah I
wrote it I wrote it for the movie so
right on man you have a daughter in the
film but uh I mean you're a young guy I
don't think you have any kids right not
that I know I don't I mean what was it I
mean you're acting and this is this is
an actress this is a professional
playing your daughter but what was it
like sort of having to get into that
gear of being dead
um well I grew up with I have a lot of
siblings I grew up I have four sisters
and one brother my youngest sister is 10
years younger than me so I kind of grew
up babysitting and like
with with kids so I I love I love kids
and it kind of was like oh I guess I
could do this
but there was a nice you know a nice
thing about handing handing the baby
back yeah yeah I also have been catching
up on Acapulco it's really really fun uh
you play a GM but you're in the Cabana
boy outfit pretty much all the time do
you just have like a whole like wardrobe
rack full of those I've got that outfit
I got like three changes because I I
tend to spill anything on in everything
when I eat on my clothes but it's only
the one outfit so I had like one fitting
and I'm good to go for the whole season
it's such a fun fun gig I'm down in
Mexico and it's you know like 85 Degrees
all the time this is a song that I wrote
for Sam
called shouty mouth wait what's it
called trouty mouth most of us obviously
first came to know you on Glee back in
2010 it's been gone for seven years but
it's still persistently in the Zeitgeist
who from the show are you still close to
do you still talk to anybody
um I mean everybody in that picture is
I'm really close with uh yeah I still
talk to uh kind of everybody when you
can kind of get a hold of them
everybody's spread out so much but uh
like I went to New York to see Darren's
show and then me and Darren kicked it in
Nashville like a couple weeks after and
I see you I see Darren all the time uh
got lunch with Harry Jenna lives across
the street from one of my best friends
and so I see her all the time and then
run into Kevin at the gym and I know I
kind of see them all whenever you know
whenever I can and uh we do like little
dinners and stuff here and there yeah
every now and then yeah I'll bet I'll
bet that's fascinating um we did pull a
little piece of video that we uh we want
to show you let's cue that up all right
so if by the time the bar closes
I carry you home to
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I mean the Arrangements on that show
were were amazing obviously you were
there you saw it happen but what goes
through your mind when you think back to
those days and you see a piece of of
video gosh it's like looking at like an
old uh photograph or an old video and
you're like wait I don't it's like you
remember it but you don't really
remember it there we did like over 700
musical numbers yeah
[Music]
various people are making the rounds to
go see Leah in funny girl are you going
to do that I might try to see it when
I'm in New York uh I've been in New York
like once since
2018 yeah so uh
I love seeing a show whenever I'm there
so you know if I get time yeah I talked
to Darren right before he's doing press
for American buffalo like right before
he had a baby it was like man how are
you gonna have a baby during this run
and then go and do American buffalo at
night that's wild gotta be a it's got to
be just a great partnership because it's
that's impossible to do that would be
impossible to do but he they they juggle
it
um very very easily and uh the baby
could not be sweeter I wouldn't saw
Darren actually
he did like he opened up at the
Hollywood Bowl uh a couple weeks ago and
I was like holding his baby while he was
while he was performing uh and it was
cool she was just sucked into like what
he was doing she's she's all about it
I've been sleep
walking in the rain
[Music]
we gotta talk music uh sleepwalking in
the rain is just out you've had your
girlfriend Camilla in a past music video
we don't care about the next day
wanna take forever living in a simple
state will she be in this music video
for sleepwalking I haven't figured out
anything with the music video side of
things yet uh I think you know once I'm
gonna when we go to New York and I come
up for air I'll probably start trying to
uh dye all that in yeah it was a
fascinating bit of trivia for me to read
that she's Suzanne Summer's
granddaughter is Suzanne Summer's like
the the most like energetic person on
the planet
um I don't think there is a sweeter
person I think she's just Charisma and
personality for days and I she's there's
no one like her she's she's amazing our
holiday meals afterwards like all right
we're gonna Thigh Master that work with
bad food off uh just kidding I I I I
think it's she's an incredible cook but
I I think it's more about you know just
eating all day and just enjoying
enjoying uh Fellowship yeah no at any
time that I met her she's been a lovely
person
um yeah you couldn't tell strong my
thighs were when I walked in yeah
I knew it I you had the look of a man
who thigh Masters seriously absolutely
right on now best of luck yeah Court
thanks so much for stopping by man
[Music]